on reçoit ce soir Annick Beaudoin qui
est propriétaire du restaurant Auguste à
Sherbrooke bonsoir bonsoir Monsieur
Filion et Antonin mousso Rivard qui est
propriétaire du Mousseau et du Molière à
Montréal bonsoir bonsoir On vous a reçu
tous les deux d'ailleurs durant la
pandémie à des moments où ça n'allait
pas très bien faut dire Madame Baudouin
d'abord et avant tout pas de panne
d'électricité de votre côté au
restaurant Augustin n'est-ce pas c'est
les avantages de l'esprit le microclimat
donc les salles de manger les salles à
manger sont pleines bah écoutez ça va
très bien la reprise est bonne
je ne cacherai pas qu'il y ait toujours
des défis à relever alors c'est sûr que
je dirais que nous sommes sortis de
cette pandémie quand même avec des
blessures qui sont toujours existantes
alors les petits aléas de la vie sont un
peu plus difficiles à traverser mais il
y a du beau il oui un beau retour quand
même on est très heureux bon on va en
parler plus en détail monsieur Mousseau
Rivard la dernière fois qu'on s'est
parlé les restaurants nedrouvrir vous
disiez accorder une dernière chance à la
restauration après la fermeture du petit
Mousseau il y a eu un changement de
formule dans vos activités il y a eu le
Molière également un autre restaurant
les affaires vont est-ce que est-ce que
les affaires vont comme vous voulez là
écoutez les affaires vont quand même pas
si mal on a réussi à passer au travers
de la crise c'était ça l'important comme
vous le voyez je suis encore là malgré
que j'avais dit que c'était ma dernière
chance que j'accordais à la restauration
j'y suis encore on voit que lumière au
bout du tunnel mais il y a beaucoup de
d'enjeux qui sont nouveaux et qui sont
quand même préoccupants dont la hausse
des coûts de denrées des coups de base
de la nourriture qui sont vraiment qui
ont explosé donc c'est sûr que les
marges pour les restaurants en ce moment
c'est pas on n'est pas dans les plus
grosses marges que les restaurants ont
pu faire en plus on est entre un entre
deux on voit que les clients on voit que
la clientèle est encore là mais elle est
un peu moins on a hâte de voir un peu
avec l'été avec les touristes qui vont
arriver mais on sent que les gens
sortent un peu moins au restaurant qui
ne sortait avant je pense que c'est en
gros maintenant à l'économie qui est de
plus en plus difficile vous constatez la
même chose avec vos doigts exactement
exactement les gens aussi ont peut-être
découvert d'autres façons de vivre leur
leur week-end ou leur sortie si on parle
de cocooning aussi toute cette
je pense c'est quand même très ancré
maintenant depuis la pandémie donc les
gens sortent pour des événements sortent
entre amis mais au quotidien je dirais
qu'un changement de mode de vie est-ce
que moins de monde qui consomme moins
mais qui paye davantage avec Baudouin
oui c'est on voit ce genre de pratique
oui c'est très agréable pour nous ça
nous motive justement à choisir des de
très bons vins de
d'avoir de nouveaux menus sur l'ardoise
de pouvoir pousser l'expérience avec les
clients mais les gens ont envie
justement de peut-être pousser
l'expérience et se détache peut-être
plus du prix au bout de la facture dans
des moments comme ça question à tous les
deux vous avez fait des efforts quand
même très importants pour revivre avec
la rareté de main d'oeuvre
comment ça se passe de votre côté
Antonin Musso River
tout le modèle d'affaires de notre
restaurant
en abolissant une partie des serveurs et
puis en redonnant vraiment
au cuisiniers la chance de servir un peu
au Tab et d'avoir une grande partie du
pourboire donc c'est un initiative qui
est très présent chez nous et qui fait
en sorte qu'on a une meilleure rétention
maintenant on a en faire aussi des
heures beaucoup plus calibré qu'avant je
veux dire avant les gens faisaient
énormément d'heures dans l'arrestation
je parle pas seulement du mien je parle
de tous les restaurants nous on est
vraiment arrivé à un point c'est entre
40 à 45 heures par semaine trois jours
de congés des conditions de travail qui
sont beaucoup plus adaptées à notre
réalité donc des vacances des journées
de maladie de faire attention à son
stage je pense que c'est une nouvelle
réalité le problème c'est que ça vient
avec un coup de faire attention à son
staff et le coup éventuellement c'est
les clients qui vont devoir le payer et
comme les restaurants on est souvent
dans les derniers à vouloir monter nos
prix face à l'inflation j'ai peur qu'on
arrive éventuellement dans un petit
clash mais pour l'instant je pense que
la plupart des restaurants l'ont vu et
le font
une meilleure conscience et voit ça de
meilleurs résultats sur comment bien
traiter le staff comment leur donner des
conditions qui sont vraiment plus
adaptées à notre réalité qu'est-ce que
vous avez dû faire vous pour retenir
votre main d'oeuvre pour trouver de la
main d'oeuvre pour déployer une équipe
stable autour de vous mais j'irai dans
le même sens que Monsieur Mousseau
écoutait les heures d'ouverture avant la
cuisine fermée à 23 heures maintenant
elle ferme à 21h travail conc
la restauration d'un autre œil avant la
restauration est un luxe accessible
maintenant ce lit de moins en moins et
malheureusement il y a une espèce de
nouvelle réalité qui est aussi les
services à la maison donc les les
services qui vont livrer de la
nourriture à la maison qui vont charger
beaucoup plus que la valeur de la
nourriture en tant que tel donc les gens
s'habituent un peu sans payer parce que
ça passe tout par carte de crédits à
manger moins bien pour payer plus cher
mais quand ils viennent le temps de bien
manger et de concentrer nos efforts sur
aider des restaurants qui font une
conciliation justement pour les employés
ou qui aident l'économie locale c'est là
qu'il faut qu'il faut dire sortir moins
sortir mieux et mettre l'argent qu'il
faut sortir dans le restaurant comme le
Mousseau c'est un peu comme boire du
café équitable on sait que tout le monde
en arrière va bien été traité qui a
aucune il y a aucun détail qui est
laissé comme tout le monde est bien donc
je pense que c'est bien important il
nous reste peu de temps je vais vous
entendre unique Baudouin sur l'enjeu des
réservations non honoré les nos shows en
anglais ça préoccupe beaucoup
l'industrie c'est quoi votre position
sur ce qui devrait se passer par rapport
à ça
je pense que plusieurs modèles
d'affaires pour ma part au restaurant on
le voit c'est minime mais c'est
croissants donc oui parce que bon
Sherbrooke c'est peut-être qu'on a une
clientèle peut-être un petit peu plus
établie mais je dirais quand même on a
vécu une dernière Saint-Valentin où on
en a eu quelques-uns quelques notions je
dirais aussi les réservations de groupe
et je vois beaucoup de collègues que ce
soit Montréal Sherbrooke réservation de
20 personnes puis ils arrivent à 12 on a
tous des téléphones on est tous capables
de communiquer on a tous des modules de
réservation
vous avez 15 secondes bah oui je pense
que on est avec la table ronde en ce
moment on est en train de vraiment mieux
s'intéresser au sujet pour inclure la
politique là-dedans je pense qu'il
éventuellement on va être capable de
pouvoir charger légalement des frais et
il y a des des modèles qu'on peut
appliquer pour pouvoir moins perdre dans
ces cas-là ce sera une prochaine
discussion malheureusement c'est que
nous avons avec Baudouin et Antonin
Musso River merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci bonne journée merci beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]